Sonntagnachmittag in Berlin Wilmersdorf
bestürztes innehalten an der
Unfallstelle liegen der monstranten das
völlig zerstörte Rad der 44-Jährigen
Frau ab zum Gedenken an das Unglück
bringen sie ein weißes Rad als Mahnmal
an
256 Radfahrer starben allein 2022 bis
Ende Juli auf deutschen Straßen doch
kaum ein Unfall sorgte für so großes
Aufsehen wie ihrer eine hass-
so nun hat die Klima RAF und Terroristen
von letzte Generation der erstes
Todesopfer auf dem Gewissen es sind
Mörder man sollte allein sperren ihr
Mörder ihr habt die Grenze gänzlich
überschritten ihr Grünen
bei den Trauernden in Berlin
Unverständnis es ist beschämend dass ein
Tod von einer Radfahrerin dass wir dann
eine Debatte über klimaschutzproteste
haben der Streit bricht am 31.10 los um
7.20 Uhr klettern zwei klimaaktivisten
auf ein autobahnschild am Dreieck
Funkturm auf der A100 in Berlin ähnlich
wie bei diesem Protest im Oktober sperrt
die Polizei zwei Fahrspuren eine bleibt
frei der dichteverkehr kommt nur noch
stockend voran die Polizei hebt die
Aktivisten mit einem Kran von der Brücke
um 8.20 Uhr überrollt ein
Betonmischfahrzeug 7 km entfernt die
44-Jährige Radfahrerin sie ist mit einem
Bein unter dem LKW eingeklemmt schwer
verletzt ein Spezialfahrzeug der
Feuerwehr rückt nach einem Notruf um
8:26 Uhr aus kommt über die Autobahn
kaum durch unsere Spezialtechnik stand
leider auf der Autobahn im Stau durch
eine Demonstration war die Autobahn
blockiert und unsere Einsatzkräfte die
ich speziell für solche Unfälle da sind
um schnell und effektiv zu retten die
kamen hier ziemlich spät der
Unfallbericht der Notärztin klingt
anders sie hatte vor Ort entschieden den
Betonmischer aus eigener Motorkraft
wegzubewegen um die Frau noch zu retten
die Süddeutsche Zeitung zitiert aus dem
Aktenvermerk
Zitat
zur Frage der technischen Rettung hat
die Notärztin klar geäußert dass sie
sich auch bei der Verfügbarkeit von
anderen technischen Möglichkeiten durch
Rüstwagen oder Kran sofort für diese
Methode entschieden hätte
Strafrechtler Benjamin grunst warnt
voreiligen Schuldzuweisungen
juristischer Perspektive brauchen wir
immer eine Kausalität das heißt die
klimaaktivisten müssen dort eine
Bedingung gesetzt haben die am Ende sich
auch in dem Schaden gezeigt hat jetzt in
Hinblick auf die Radfahrerin könnte man
natürlich an der fahrlässige Tötung
fahrlässige Körperverletzung denken
dafür dass mir aber bisher an der
Kausalität so dass ich da keine weiteren
Straftatbestände sehe trotzdem aus allen
politischen Richtungen hagelt es Kritik
und Schuldzuweisungen
all das hat mit einer demokratischen
Auseinandersetzung überhaupt nichts zu
tun die Straftäter müssen schnell und
konsequent verfolgt werden
wer mit seinem Protest Gesundheit und
Leben von anderen riskiert büsst damit
jede Legitimität ein und schadet auch
der Klimabewegung selbst
der Kuschelkurs mit den
klima-terroristen muss ein Ende haben
hier ist ein hartes Durchgreifen gefragt
Soziologe Simon Theune forscht zu
Protesten er sieht kein Gewaltpotenzial
bei den klimaaktivisten da kann man ganz
klar sagen das hat mit Terrorismus
überhaupt nichts zu tun Terrorismus sind
sozusagen geplante Gewalttaten um
politische Entscheidungen zu erzwingen
weder in der Klimabewegung gibt es in
der Klimabewegung eine relevante Gruppe
die solche Aktionsformen in Erwägung
zieht noch gibt es überhaupt eine
Debatte darüber dass das legitim sein
würde Berlin Rosenthaler Platz
vergangenen Freitag die letzte
Generation bei einer unangemeldeten
Straßenblockade die Stimmung ist
angespannt auch bei Benjamin Fink binnen
Sekunden kleben Sie sich auf der
verkehrsreichen Straße fest riskieren
dafür strafen das gehört zum zivilen
Widerstand dazu dass wir bewusst Gesetze
rechenbewusst Grenzen übertreten das
mache ich nicht leichtfertig ich würde
auch gerne
weiter demonstrieren aber das wurde
schon die letzten 30 Jahre gemacht
demonstriert und Petition unterschrieben
sie sehen keinen anderen Weg mehr und
setzen ihren Protest fort
ich sitze hier weil wir seit der von der
wissenschaftszeit mehr als 30 Jahren
davor gewarnt werden dass wir in der
Klimakatastrophe Rasen und die Regierung
schafft nicht mal einfacher
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen wie in 100 km/h
Tempolimit oder das neue die
Wiedereinführung des 9-euro-tickets
umzusetzen München auch bei BMW gehen
Klimaschützer weiter als bei normalen
Demonstrationen dieses mal sind es vor
allem Wissenschaftler organisiert bei
der Gruppe scientist Rebellion sie
überschütten mehrere BMW mit Farbe und
kleben sich fest der bayerische Staat
reagiert mit aller Härte 16 Aktivisten
kommen für mehrere Tage in eine
sogenannte Präventivhaft Grundlage dafür
ein umstrittenes Polizeigesetz es macht
möglich Menschen ohne Anklage oder
Prozess in Haft zu stecken
es braucht deutlich härtere Strafen für
klimakaoten um einer weiteren
Radikalisierung in Teilen dieser
Klimabewegung entgegenzuwirken und
Nachahmer abzuschrecken die Entstehung
einer Klima RAF muss verhindert werden
die Molekularbiologin Nana Maria Grüning
ist regelmäßig bei den Protestaktionen
von scientist Rebellion dabei hartre
Strafen so sagt sie halten sie nicht ab
diese zwei drei Jahre die wir jetzt
haben das sind die wichtigsten
wahrscheinlich für immer in menschlichen
Zeiträumen und deshalb konzentriert die
Klimabewegung gerade alle Energie in
diese Proteste wir wollen auf alle Fälle
weitermachen also wir haben eigentlich
gar keine andere moralische Wahl weil
die Regierung immer noch nicht
angemessen auf die Klimakatastrophe
reagiert das Deutschland beim
Klimaschutz versagt hat sehen nicht nur
Umweltaktivisten so auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
Bundesregierung in einem historischen
Urteil aufgefordert deutlich mehr für
den Klimaschutz zu tun der Klimabewegung
ist es so dass sich das Zeitfenster in
dem
politisch wirksame Maßnahmen getroffen
werden können sehr schnell schließt und
das
die Aktionen sozusagen sich daran messen
lassen müssen wie welche Politik gemacht
wird und man sieht gerade dass es dass
das zu Verzweiflung führt in Berlin
versucht Benjamin Fink nach der Aktion
sofort die Straße erneut zu blockieren
die Polizei stoppt ihn vorerst die
Klimaschützer planen schon wieder neue
Aktionen